the Secret Service special agent
entrance exam has logic questions like
this one some Secret Service employees
are special agents Melissa is a secret
service special agent Stacy has never
been to Georgia all secret service
special agents have been to Georgia
Frank works with Stacy indicate true
false or insufficient information for
each statement one Stacy is a secret
service special agent two Melissa has
been to Georgia three Frank works for
the Secret Service
we know that all secret service special
agents have been to Georgia and Stacy
has never been to Georgia so Stacy is a
secret service special agent is false
then we know that Melissa is a special
agent and all special agents have been
to Georgia so the second statement is
true finally Frank works with Stacy and
we know Stacy is not a special agent
however not all secret service employees
are special agents so Stacy may or may
not work at the Secret Service so the
answer to three is there is not enough
information to decide